par parler de jean luc mélenchon celui
ci était au brésil pour aller voir l'ex
président lula faisait couler tant est
en prison à curitiba pour corruption et
jean luc mélenchon 1 est convaincu que
le la est victime d'un a été victime
d'un procès politique
et deux qu'il est dans le même cas
écoutez le je serai moi même en procès
politique la fin du mois de septembre ce
sera un moment très triste pour mon pays
parce que il n'y avait pas eu de procès
politique depuis la période de la guerre
d'algérie en france
ce sera un moment triste pour mon pays
je deviens trop ce procès rappelons le
s'est pas empressé m'empresser politique
c'est parce que les planches en a pas
collaborer avec la justice ou moins
d'une perquisition
oui enfin pas que la bresse est encore à
neuf et nice mascré il s'en est pris de
bienveillant voilà il savait prêt
physiquement à dépositaires de
l'autorité judiciaire qui étaient là
pour la perquisition il a il a dit c'est
son entourage qui est elle a enfoncé la
porte
donc il ya des faits ça n'a rien d'un
procès politique mais en revanche on
retrouve la vieille stratégie de
victimisation de jean luc mélenchon
l'ennemi et à la justice et les médias
parce que lui aussi l'accusé aussi les
médias de nourrir ce procès politique
notamment l'express par par lequel il a
appris qu'il serait jugé en
correctionnelle alors que lui disait
qu'il ne le savait pas encore et c'est
une stratégie de victimisation qui
constitue une diversion opportune au
score de manants aubry sa tête de liste
aux européennes 6,2 et puis à des à des
problèmes plus récent qu'on a vu cet été
avec l'université d'été de la france est
soumise
les amphis de la france a soumises où il
ya eu deux sévères divergences entre
partisans de la laïcité et
communautariste et même des départs à
cause de ça de la france a soumis
divergences avant des vacances à voir si
on pouvait légitimement critiquer
l'islam ou à être islamophobe on pouvait
se dire islamophobes ou pas et
divergences sur lesquels jean luc
mélenchon s'est bien gardé de prendre la
parole parce qu'il est très enquiquiner
et les persuader que si jamais ils
s'expriment que ce soit dans un sens ou
dans l'autre il perd la moitié sont
partis alors peut-être que là on
entrevoit envie de venir en défense de
jean luc mélenchon mais en tout cas pour
ça il ne faut pas compter sur gilles
legendre
le patron de la république en marche à
l'assemblée on a l'habitude à chaque
fois que jean luc mélenchon va en
amérique du sud
il renoue avec une sorte de romantisme
révolutionnaire un peu narcissique qui
se victimise je lui dirai juste une
joute jean-luc revient à paris voilà on
attend impatiemment non attends mais non
mais si c'est pour dire des bêtises
pareilles il faut mieux qu'il reste à
paris qui embarrasse vous avez un petit
peu de de sympathie pour ce romantisme
révolutionnaire pour le romantisme
révolutionnaire d'amérique du sud non
mais pour je dirais la stratégie de
mélenchon je trouve ça plutôt bien joué
et c'est la règle du jeu là une
perquisition chez lui
il essaye de jouer effectivement à la
victime alors évidemment il a fait un
mauvais sketch je suis la république
non il est au service de la république
mais enfin il avait même dit à dire que
par ailleurs il ya des juges qui
eux-mêmes pense qu'ils sont la justice
alors que eux mêmes ne sont que au
service de la justice
bon ça a été dit il est évident qu'ils
essayent de transformer cette procédure
judiciaire est bien comme un tremplin
pour essayer de ressouder son camp
politique
et c'est de cette bonne guerre donc par
conséquent sincèrement je ne vois pas en
quoi ce serait particulièrement
scandaleux qu'ils essayent de 2,2 de
s'opposer
je dirais enfin de huy de déclarer que
cette procédure est une procédure
politique
et puis encore une fois il ya il ya une
perquisition chez lui c'est la moindre
des choses qu'ils essayent de résister
d'une certaine manière parce que l'état
est aux est au service des citoyens et
pâle inverse donc d'une certaine manière
non moi j'ai plutôt de la sympathie là
pour le coup pour jean luc mélenchon et
et sa tentative un peu hasardeuse faut
quand même bien le dire d'essayer de
ressouder son parti politique parce que
le fond du problème c'est ça c'est la
divergence entre indigéniste et
républicains et et c'est ça qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui
jean luc mélenchon dans une position
compliquée oui on va tous vous partagez
cette simple début de sympathie bernard
voilà pour la rade la sympathie ou de
l'antipathie non mais je suis en
désaccord avec un élément qui a soulevé
jeudi d'entre eux pied l'habitude de
de l'extrême gauche ou du camp de jean
luc mélenchon de mettre en cause de la
justice pour suivre ça de près c'est la
première fois en fait qu'ils ont cette
posture dans le camp de mélenchon de
mettre en cause la justice jusqu'à
présent lors des affaires de fillon lors
des démêlés de marine le pen à quelle
justice y avait toujours eu le discours
de dire il faut respecter la justice etc
mais bien sûr mais justement c'est un
tournoi important il me semble mais je
pense qu'il n'est pas tout à fait
dépourvue alors il ya les outrances
verbales un évidement de le procès
politique s'était tout de suite les la
guerre d'algérie convoqué bon c'est un
jeu la salle à le parler avec lula et
c'est non mais il ya quand même des
éléments intéressants
par exemple le tout les gens qui
s'intéressent un peu au sujet sont
d'accord pour dire que la perquisition
était totalement disproportionnée dans
ses moyens qu'elle est intervenue le
jour d'un remaniement ministériel
qu'elle ne peut pas s'être fait sans que
le mystère majorité soit au courant et
dans le même temps on est une indulgence
assez spectaculaire de la justice
s'agissant du gouvernement je vais
donner quelques exemples l'appertisation
élections de benalla qui s'est arrêté
puisqu'on ne pouvait pas ouvrir le
coffre dans laquelle il y aurait
peut-être des armes
le procureur de paris rémy heitz qui a
été choisi par emmanuel macron contre
l'avis de garde des sceaux qui avait
trois autres candidats et plus récemment
on a eu le procureur de la république de
nice qui a avoué lui-même qui n'avait
disculper la police dans le cas de la
sphère de geneviève le jet pour ne pas
embarrasser le président donc c'est vrai
qu'il ya des éléments contre les
oppositions dans l'appel jean luc
mélenchon est aussi marine le pen
françois fillon et c est sa gestion du
gouvernement qui quand même jette le
trouble
peut-être pas sûr sur seulement sur
l'indépendance mais sur l'impartialité
de la justice je pense que c'est quand
même un élément intéressant à débattre
le révolutionnaire bolivarien
jean luc mélenchon peux tu nous parler
de son pays favorisent venezuela parce
que c'est une catastrophe planétaire
vous avez été décrit par les médias ce
qu'il faut voir c'est remettre peut-être
les choses en perspective à l'époque
jean luc mélenchon temps une stratégie
assez fine
rappelez vous à l'époque c'était quand
le leadership des manuels macron donc
quand il a quand il affleure son grand
cinéma
ah oui au moment des agressions emmanuel
macron est en perte du leadership
on vous le dit il est dans une période
où des grands ministres de son mouvement
partent passer à bellenaves ménal à
l'opposition en tout cas le match entre
marine le pen et lui en tant que
opposant numéro un n'est pas
véritablement tranché même si la droite
a essayé de se relever lors des
européennes avec la campagne de françois
xavier dans la bible la droite non plus
n'a pas retrouvé son leader son chef
charismatique et donc en ayant cette
posture
jean luc mélenchon tentent de dire je
suis un vrai leader et il le fait trop
il le fait trop
s'affichant comme ça il tentait de
passer des messages pour créer de la
porosité entre tout un tas de mouvements
politiques et ils se trompent
complètement
il va un tout petit peu trop loin
pendant qu'ils aient tant sur la police
puisque certaines images ont montré
qu'ils avaient été totalement
irrespectueux par rapport à ce
commandant de police qui n'a pas
beaucoup témoigné mais ce serait
intéressant de l'entendre un peu plus et
des représentants de la justice comme
l'a dit juil
judith et donc il va un petit peu trop
loin il rate complètement il rate
complètement son pari et il s'aperçoit
deux semaines plus tard que sa stratégie
n'est absolument pas payante dans les
sondages et à partir de ça et bien sans
chaînes différentes catastrophes
charlot dirhams et plus en phase avec
certaines positions du mouvement
c'est un dessin qui aurait donc voilà on
va exactement et puis un peu à l'image
de ce parti s'est alors pardon je vais
faire des associations de concepts qui
sont peut-être un peu bête mais à
l'image de ce parti socialiste qui à
l'époque avait perdu strauss kahn est
obligé de se réfugier dans les bras de
françois hollande finalement manon aubry
est désignée leader de la france a
soumises alors qu'elle n'était pas du
tout armé pour faire ça
jean luc mélenchon à l'époque quand il
fait ce pari là il est dans cet état
d'esprit
eh bien il est très faible aujourd'hui
il est affaibli et je crois qu'en plus
il n'a pas la volonté de reprendre les
rênes de ce mouvement on voit bien qu'il
a peut-être la pente
la tentation que de carla bruni à
nouveau puisque vous rappeler qu'il
avait quand même concédé écouté les
albums de carla bruni quand il était un
peu non panneaux 0 mais sans doute un
peu triste donc il est dans cette
situation là si demain il est embastillé
et qu'il essaye de se décrire comme un
membre des luchonnais
maintenant ce sera le mandela de la
france je pense qu'il en fait un peu
trop personne n'est dupe et puis
politiquement
qu'est ce qu'il offre pour la prochaine
grande échéance électorale qui sont les
moins sachant qu'on sait très bien que l
efi et les municipales je pars toujours
sur le contrôle de gîtes là c'est
absolument pas le scrutin qui leur va
donc c'est vrai que les prochaines
étapes sont très mauvaises pour pour ce
mouvement qui se porte mal je me trompe
adrien matou faisait état de vingt dix
de politisation de
la justice ça vous paraît être une
inquiétude ou un soupçon justifié
ça me parait oui mais ça n'empêche pas
et on peut trouver que jean luc
mélenchon n'est pas victime d'un procès
politique et que par ailleurs certains
juges se conduisent de façon partiale
on l'a vu par exemple avec les affaires
sarkozy la façon dont le juge tournaire
à mener son instruction avant la sortie
viège a été l'objet de critiques et ayez
de la part notamment du journal du
dimanche qui a sorti vraiment des
éléments je tends un doute très fort sur
sûr comme socialisation sur le giro mais
pour mélenchon vient donc effectivement
c'est il ya un doute sur sur sur la
justice quand elle a à faire sur des
juges de ne pas dire la justice parce
que je crois pas que la justice
l'éducation nationale à au delà de les
juges il ya le lien entre le parquet et
le gouvernement par exemple qu'il y a
quand même un lien de subordination
directe pour le coup mais là je pensais
plus localisation vous rappelle que les
acquisitions elles sont faites à la
demande du parquet sous le contrôle du
procureur ou de son représentant
passez un sujet économique si vous le
voulez bien la compagnie aigle azur
c'est une compagnie aérienne connaissent
bien notamment ceux qui vont en afrique
du nord
cette compagnie on le savait connaissait
de grandes difficultés
aujourd'hui elle est carrément en
faillite
d'ailleurs bien malheureux pour les
pauvres passagers qui sont bloqués dans
des pays étrangers qui ne peuvent plus
revenir en france puisque les vols sont
interrompus et la question se pose déjà
est ce que l'état doit intervenir pour
aider cette entreprise qui a des
capitaux privés
comme on pouvait s'y attendre c'est le
souhait des syndicats par exemple la
fédération force ouvrière des transports
qui considère que le ministère justement
des transports doit prendre toutes ses
responsabilités et bien on va l'écouter
les ministères des transports en la
personne de son nouveau
secrétaire d'état il vient d'arriver au
gouvernement c'est jean baptiste
djebbari il était ce matin sur rtl
et pour lui il serait pas illogique
l'état accompagne ou essaient de
susciter des projets de reprise écoutez
d'abord l'état a gelé un certain nombre
de dettes sociales et fiscales de
manière à préserver l'activité le plus
longtemps possible pour permettre
notamment le rapatriement des passagers
et la continuation de l'activité
ensuite l'état et c'est son rôle quand
même principal s'assure de la sécurité
des vols il faut que les vols qui sont
réalisés puisse être fait en toute
sécurité
l'état accompagne ou tentent de susciter
les projets de reprise
essart monde en parlera peut-être un
tout petit peu plus tard effectivement
il ya un système d'entre aide
internationale dès lors qu'une compagnie
est en cessation de vol qui fait que les
compagnies aériennes peuvent affréter
des vols
guillaume bernard une entreprise privée
qui fait faillite est ce que c'est le
rôle de l'état de dd à des repreneurs
au-delà des questions de sécurité dont
évidemment on peut penser qu'elles sont
en qu'elles sont légitimes
en principe nous oui je vous étonne
puisque je ne suis pas libéral mais a
pris mais mais mais jouer le mejhoul vie
mais oui mais je vous prend à
contre-pied en principe au début donc se
sentir un codicille la précision c'est
est ce qu'il s'agit d'une activité qui
relève de la puissance de l'état est ce
qu'il est ce qu'il s'agit d'une activité
économique qui concerne l'aménagement du
territoire je crois que l'état a toute
sa place et doit nécessairement
intervenir lorsqu'il s'agit de
l'indépendance nationale lorsqu'il
s'agit d'une activité industrielle par
exemple qui contribue à l'indépendance
du pays
en revanche pour ce qui concerne
une compagnie aérienne je ne suis pas
certain que il y est absolument la
nécessité
que l'état se substitue aux acteurs
privés et semble-t-il à une défaillance
dans la gestion de cette entreprise
alors que l'on s'occupe de rapatrier nos
compatriotes
ça c'est une des premières choses pas
tous les clients de la compagnie il
s'agit pas d'assurer aux frais du
contribuable français tout tous les vols
qui étaient prévus qui avaient été
vendus de rapatrier les compatriotes qui
est sont à l'étranger qui ne peuvent pas
rentrer et ça c'est une des premières
choses et ensuite effectivement que
l'état depuis ce contribué à ce qu'une
activité contre continue sans doute mais
sans que cela soit pour autant payer par
le contribuable
en revanche je le maintiens s'il s'agit
d'une activité la sidérurgie le
nucléaire dans le cas pour lesquels là
il ya un enjeu d'indépendance nationale
et de puissance géopolitique de la
france là pour le coup le fait que je ne
sois pas libéral me conduit
naturellement à considérer que l'état
doit être présent alors nos internautes
sont sur la même longueur d'onde que
vous chers guillaume bernard puisque à
la question posée sur twitter l'état
doit-il sauvé aigle azur
vous êtes 71% à répondre non alors avant
de continuer le débat je vous d'écouter
un autre argument qui pourrait plaider
en faveur d'un soutien public à cette
compagnie privée c'est que il y a de
moins en moins d'opérateurs aérien sous
pavillon français écoutent et martin
surzur c'est le président du syndicat
des pilotes des glazers plus largement
on peut regretter que la france berceau
de l'aviation soit en passe de devenir
le pays européens au pavillon le moins
étoffé réduit bientôt à la seule
compagnie air france
faut savoir que xl airways va très mal
corsair ne va pas forcément tellement
mieux donc air france risque d'être
encerclés par la concurrence européenne
est donc menacé à moyen terme dans son
intégrité